let's go girls indeed thank you Shania
Twain our series changing the game
Highlights Highlights rather
extraordinary women making a difference
now and for future Generations this
morning we are so excited to introduce
you to Kim Roxy she started a Makeup
Company it's called lamik Beauty in her
College apartment back in 2004. Roxy
said she couldn't find makeup that
worked for her her skin tone and was
made with natural ingredients so she
decided I'm going to create my own now
her products are sold Nationwide they've
been worn by big names like Meghan
Markle we like oh Tiffany haddish like
her too Kim Roxy joins us now to discuss
hey Kim so take us to your college
apartment you're sitting there
you thought I need to do some well what
was begging me was the fact that my
beauty was not being celebrated so as a
dark-skinned woman who grew up in the
south in Houston Texas the culture
around me a lot of times was about being
lighter skin
yes and so I wanted to create something
that celebrated me
um because I knew I was beautiful I
looked at my mother my sisters they're
beautiful I am too and so I wanted to
create something like that so I opened
up my own makeup studio in Houston so
what does that mean I opened up my
makeup studio what did you do yeah so
what I did was
um I opened up a place where we could
get our makeup done where we could get
our eyebrows done where we could get our
lashes done and so I started doing that
in the mall took out a lease at 21 years
old
um and started taking customers from the
food court because I had no customers to
my makeup place and then started so how
did you expand it nationwide to other
people yeah so after running that makeup
studio for 14 years I had already
started trinkling with my products
creating different things and I decided
that in 2020 I was going to launch my
brand nationally and the pandemic
happened so the same time I planned the
launch was March 2020. so what did you
do so I turned on my camera and did like
everybody else did I went Facebook live
and I went live in my daughter's bedroom
she was you and your daughter just me
and my daughter she was four years old
at the time I was trying to get her out
the room I was like look I'm trying to
sell something I'm trying to launch this
brand what was your pitch on on camera
so when I got on camera I showed up with
no makeup on and I said let me show you
what I do we're watching something yes
and I started showing them how I create
my brows so I have a form of alopecia
and it caused hair loss and it happened
on my eyebrows so my first product I
created was my Revelation brow Duo and I
feel in my eyebrows with it and then I
put the little concealer underneath Tony
you see it right yeah but it looks like
a Flawless it looks like you have hair
you do not have I do not have hair up
there that is filled oh that is field
don't your Browns look good yeah thank
you so I decided to do that because your
browse frame 75 percent of your face yes
and so I needed my brows okay the hair I
can do but I need my brows and so that's
what I decided to create and my daughter
she just been on the journey with me and
we've been selling online and since then
we've launched in major retailers and
it's been amazing oh we were just
shouting out moms you are a mom but yes
I love the fact that your late mom was
your very first investor was it a yes or
a hell yes yeah take me through that
moment when you said Mom I need help to
do this will you help look at that
picture wow I mean if I could have told
Mom back then you know
not even 20 years from now I'll be
sitting in the living room with Gail and
Vlad and Tony she would say hell yes but
at the time she said she said yes she
said here's 500 she said let's do this
my sisters rallied around me they were
like let's do this what does lamik stand
for the meek stands for love and makeup
and kindness nice
um and my dad you know
I'm a preacher's kid and so anything I
do I got to bring love to it and so with
lamik beauty is revealed not applied and
that means that means I think it's
applied
but what I'm saying is this everybody
may not see your beauty for what it is
you have to know it and so for me it's
about beauty it's revealed the more we
show it it might be your talents that
make you feel beautiful it might be your
skill set but just reveal it to the
world and they will be attracted to you
okay Kim love that Bravo I'm dead love
that
[Laughter]
yes it is love and makeup and kindness
love and makeup and kindness thank you
very much for being here we'll be right
back stay with us guys